heights but why did you want the tights
so bad that you would there's so many
other because i just want to see if i
could do it okay david that's what you
want to hear i just want to see if i
could do it my father wasn't around
my mother absentee
stealing feels the hole in my heart
there's somebody in my family that i've
learned later in my life
who was
very you know he was very involved in
armed robbers
who i'm not going to say i think that's
your limitation
are you for reals yeah like this dude in
a five four
three
two
one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast i'd like to start this podcast
with an intervention
with this man
pat did you know this about nick god bro
how many times you gonna bring this up
that nick steals
you steal dick steals
all the time kind of in my blood though
you know
the funniest [ __ ] thing dude so we
were at target
no we weren't at target we were at the
city this [ __ ] drunk dog you
don't know his [ __ ] story what
happened get your story straight we're
at the gym
we're lifting weights it's a beautiful
night by the way how how this
information was disclosed to the group
was also very interesting it was very
unnecessary it was very it was very
telling literally be doing a chest press
and then tiff comes up she goes nick
steals
[ __ ] [ __ ] what are you doing
i don't know where i don't know where
she just she's just i don't know why i'm
targeting all the time she thought it
would be funny to to let uh not all that
what do you what are you stealing this
was years ago honestly i almost forgot
this was like
last year 2020 yeah pandemic was rough
right that wasn't a year ago yeah yeah
no it was like 20
i don't know like 2016 like it was like
when i was like back fighting and [ __ ] i
was like 21. so what were you stealing i
was stealing tights guys yeah sports
types why because you know why i looked
at the tag and i was like i'm paying 40
for this yeah so then i went in the
dressing room put them on under my pants
oh walked out
how many times did you do it though your
little winona ryder [ __ ]
i just wanted to feel alive
it's kind of fun
you just wanted to watch the world burn
a little bit yeah i was like nordstrom's
is next i was like i'm doing i'm doing
small time i'm gonna do something big
time yeah what's the biggest thing
you've ever stole probably that
tights no but why did you want the
tights so bad that you would there's so
many others i just want to see if i
could do it okay david that's what you
want to hear i just want to see if i
could do it my father wasn't around
my mother absentee
stealing feels the hole in my heart
there's somebody in my family that i've
learned later in my life who was
very you know like he was very involved
in armed robbery
who i'm not gonna say i think i stashed
your limitations still around you know
yeah are you for reals yeah like this
dude literally had to run
yeah bro and you know what he said to me
one time he goes he goes you don't know
what it's like to have the power of a
gun pointing at someone's head and i was
like who the [ __ ] are you why would he
say that because the [ __ ] is right
because he's crazy hey he's crazy bro
yeah that's that's some well that [ __ ] i
know exactly who he's talking about yeah
you know the story and like he would
tell me which is why
it's literally nick
smith why i like them even more like
after i heard that story i was like i
knew i liked this fool for a reason yeah
you know
it's not consensual sex and i'm like yo
actually your boy does you're a piece of
[ __ ] bro
damn and this dude happy birthday dick
cheers
it's a six-year-old birthday this dude
was like into armed robbery when he was
like real young and [ __ ]
hell yeah i had no idea certain people
in my family don't even know how what
were you talking about like seven years
old eight years old when did he tell you
this when he told me when i was like
around the time i was stealing from
target oh it was another intervention
it's my boy
he knew i was stealing [ __ ] from target
and he was like still my boy
yeah you were the prodigy dude it's all
starting to come together dude he's like
all right he goes you gotta dip this in
the bud though yeah nip this in the butt
but you only steal from big corporations
like target you don't steal from small
businesses do you not
that that was that was like only
like once or twice did you get caught
ever no never bro i got caught one time
hey this dude has a crazy story you got
caught stealing bro you know what pisses
me off is that it it's kind of come full
circle recently but uh i was just turned
18 i stole batteries from a right aid
and it had like loss prevention i didn't
know what loss prevention was dude but
some dude just confronted me i didn't i
didn't want to pay for that i wanted to
play xbox didn't want to pay for the
batteries they were too [ __ ]
expensive [ __ ] that i get that bro see i
was pissed i was like and then i was all
like on some robin hood [ __ ] where i was
like these corporations make so much
money
stealing is the best thing
i love that [ __ ] i jacked these
batteries and i would do it all the time
but this guy was
looked like a citizen like he looked
like a like just a normal dude and he
comes out he was just like the skinny
black dude and he got like in my face
and was like hey what the [ __ ] my wife
so i just i had my took his job waiting
i had my raisin that's real because i
bought raisin nets to like throw people
off the street
if i'm buying [ __ ] i wouldn't be
stealing [ __ ] you know i buy a one
dollar thing because it's like why would
you do that he was like first fighting
nobody likes raising dance
you lying what are you [ __ ] 80 years
old and you like raising nets bro i've
always loved raising it i thought about
that today weirdest candies dog bro i
thought about that today i honestly it
took me a long time to know that raisins
and grapes were the same things i didn't
know that until like two years ago tired
you like raisin nets i like raisin nuts
why i did just chocolate raisins baby
i like raisins bro i like chocolate you
suspect bro he likes movie theater you
like yeah you like faces
who the hell calling me right now i also
like oatmeal raisin cookies
that's not that bad okay wait hold on a
second what are you ready
like you ate a razor net and then you
were like this is the [ __ ] ever since
i think this is more egregious than you
stealing batteries yeah because i don't
think about the thievery and [ __ ] i i
cared that you thought that buying
raisin nests wasn't suspicious chocolate
covered reason you weren't throwing off
any scent that made you more suspicious
he's like what does a [ __ ] body
raise a nest he's 18. yeah
i actually no i didn't like episode i
did try them i like charleston shoes
[ __ ] excuse me
do you have a pack of saltwater taffy
they'll never catch me
charleston shoes were nice a bag of
rocks what the [ __ ] is the charleston
it's chocolate covered nougat
okay nougat um
so anyway so i checked these batteries
and uh this dude confronts me i like
shoved him and then he was like i'm
gonna call the cops and he showed me the
battery case and i ran and it was in
south pasadena that write it on mission
i know that one i go to that one all the
time and i'm well i go there now but i
think i don't know if they banned me for
i don't know what happened because his
face was up everywhere anyways the cop
the cops come it's how passing a police
response is like literally like crime
committed cops right here like what the
hell they're right there and it's across
the street the police station's across
so
the whole like i ran to this like little
this apartment complex that i used to
play at as a kid and like i hid in the
laundry room and there was just cops
everywhere like motorcycle cops cops
cruising through the alley and then i
heard a helicopter i heard a [ __ ]
can i just say something right now
this is how little action south pasadena
sees they found a young little man that
stole [ __ ] batteries and he had
raisin nets and now they're expensive
bro call in the chopper
where the [ __ ] are the batteries
they're waterboarding me in the back
um so dude i ran i ran after i heard the
helicopter ran to a mcdonald's on fair
oaks and it was a hot summer day and i
was like [ __ ] i gotta they the police
have my description right so i had like
a black tea shorts and i had a hat on
and i had a tank top under it and so i
was like i need to like change my
visuals so i go into the bathroom i take
my shirt and my hat off and i stuff it
under a booth and i'm just sitting there
at mcdonald's and i'm telling you
there's cops [ __ ] everywhere like
everywhere everywhere and people are
starting to like look around like what's
going on batteries i get up i'm like i'm
just sitting i'm sitting here empty i'm
sitting here empty-handed i was like i
gotta like blend in so i went i was like
i gotta buy a vanilla cone like that's
my move so i'm sorry man
yo
look your plan is always the same i
gotta buy some weird [ __ ]
i gotta buy some soft ass [ __ ] and eat
it inside just to throw off the set bro
but it kind of worked because i got the
vanilla cone as i got the vanilla cone a
cop walked in with it with his taser in
his hand like he like watched it
dude
he already had taser in his hand like
this like he had it ready to rock
someone got stopped these cops i got the
vanilla cone and like i we turned looked
at each other and then i was just i had
to just act normal so i just like walked
by him but my [ __ ] heart is beating
beyond belief
well i thought he might have i kept
walking but he went into the bathroom
where i changed and i just sat there and
people were like what the [ __ ] and i was
just eating my ice cream like a lunatic
vanilla cream
battery skin
bro so i got i went to bristol farms i
went to bristol farms up the street
which what did you buy there bro i just
was looking through magazines i stole
more batteries
i was just looking at like oprah
mcdonald's more raisin nets
furniture and [ __ ] like patio like
awnings and stuff and then uh good
housekeeping called a friend said pick
me up he picked me up i got away but
then they just checked the tapes and
they were like they figured out that it
was me did you just the funny thing is
just to throw out that said you probably
bought like 86 dollars in trinkets but
you could have just paid for the
batteries
and i spent way more money it was like
how much did you spend on this random
[ __ ] i spent 172 dollars buy the
batteries man just kidding me over a
bunch of magazines expensive too bro but
what pisses me off as i was at right at
the like couple weeks ago and some guy
walked out and and uh like the beeper
went up beep beep and the girl that was
bringing me out she's like oh he just
stole something and i was like and i was
like oh [ __ ] so i'm expecting like the
swat team because this is what happened
to me and i was like oh [ __ ] so like
what's gonna happen and she was like oh
nothing like we just we don't really do
anything about it different time and i
was like well what why the [ __ ] did you
guys call the helicopter for my ass i
didn't want to say that you're like a
helicopter expensive as [ __ ] yeah i
didn't i didn't want to read you i
didn't want to reignite the band you
know i didn't want to be like well i
stole here years ago and then they'd be
like oh what like get the [ __ ] out of
here don't come back i didn't want to
like patrick get the [ __ ] out of here
like but i really remember you
but i was pissed that you got away and
they were like i was like so you're not
gonna do anything you know i was like go
get his ass yeah
you should have confronted like the
other black people
yeah yeah maybe he didn't work there
maybe it was just a guy that like was
pissed that he could maybe you know it's
because you shoved the loss prevention
guy oh that's and that was grounds for
batteries
yeah so where do they find you uh well
they they my dad called me i was like
the cops are here looking for you and i
was like [ __ ] if i wasn't they were
watching i would have been so pissed at
the cops i was like batteries dude
for [ __ ] batteries i guarantee you
what happened the reason why that
doesn't happen is because of that [ __ ]
they wasted so much of the city's money
maybe they're like are you [ __ ] dumb
it was batteries yeah are you out of
your [ __ ] mind probably yeah that's
the funniest thing how much does it cost
to to charge up a helicopter
a lot of [ __ ] gasoline and how do
they get an island you gotta pay the
pilot right hourly or whatever that's
overtime bro that's overtime for the
block the pilot hanging out i don't know
when he's not flying she's sad
some kids stealing batteries
one [ __ ] chinese cop you're sitting
out there somebody please call me
anybody i just find anybody swear to god
just wait just somebody to call me i
want to be batman please somebody
oh my god dude yeah bro but that's some
[ __ ] i've never ever you know i i've
actually stole a couple things people
have stolen for me i never stole myself
though
i think you would have other people
still what do you think you're better
than us this guy thinks it's like a
mastermind oh 100 i'm better than you
guys
i've never had no cop chase no nothing
else you never ran from the cops ever in
your life
it's pretty exhilarating yeah it's
pretty fun oh i'm missing out it's kind
of fun it's a good time i mean if you
get away it's like like what else was
that bro
i've been fighting my whole life
they're gonna catch me
i've definitely been like harassed by
cops but i've never been
in trouble for stealing [ __ ] because
during like early when i was in high
school that was during the time there
was a lot of like asian gang violence so
they were just bullying any asian kid
even me i was like this fat kid with
glasses and like split hair it looks
like i just all i do is read all day and
like what gang activity are you in the
day i'm like i'm reading i'm just being
racist they're being racist bro yeah
it's like i'm reading a book what the
[ __ ] who's gonna steal a book like what
are you talking about i read about
wizards and dwarves
you're gonna [ __ ] beat me up for this
you [ __ ] meanies
oh my god dude but they didn't know i
was gangbanging all the time
i bought an ice cream cone
threw up the sand i was like what coke
bottle glasses and ice cream he does a
gang bang
you can't be doing a criminal [ __ ] with
a vanilla comb baby
can't be doing it it's just got to be
cool for you
you know what that's actually pretty
smart that you switched clothes and then
you stuffed it under because he's a
criminal mastermind and it was in the
heat of the moment out that i was like
[ __ ] like i'm glad i had that
wherewithal in that moment wait what
were the consequences you were in jail
for humbling i went to jail for
years yeah yeah i went to jail for a
night and then uh for batteries yo i
went to jail had pb js with this guy
reggie which somehow like oh [ __ ]
something black dude named reggie who
kept telling me he didn't do it like i
was the one that arrested him like he
kept being like i didn't do it man and
i'd be like all right cool man like you
know the crime i was in there for uh
is that the cells are supposed to be
closed and and they keep the light on
all the time so it's like the most
uncomfortable [ __ ] ever but somehow i
tried to just sleep my whole
time there off but somehow the door like
reggie at one point was in like myself
like the cell was open he was in my
doorway and i was like how the [ __ ] did
you get in here reggie and he was like
come on out here he was like alone like
he was like wanted to hang out with
somebody said come on man i'm by myself
you want to hang out and i'd be like i
was like how the [ __ ] do you get in here
right
what do you look like without your
t-shirt
let me see that white beard let me see
that white beard your dick smell like
i'll tell you what my dick smell like
smell like flowers
you're like oh i'm intrigued now this is
getting really [ __ ] weird dude
so i hung out with reggie is cool bro
it was not cool
that she was not cool let me smell your
dick he was he was like it was just like
a cra like being with a crazy dude
and then i did community service so i
had to clean parks like i had 145 hours
ago literally back in the day south
pasadena had nothing to do that is
literally the biggest waste of [ __ ]
money i've ever heard in my life there
are the highland park is right around
the corner
like if you want to look for some [ __ ]
to do like [ __ ] that many years ago
there was plenty of [ __ ] to do in
hollywood don't you have to steal a
certain amount of like merchandise for
them well even stores for them to take
that that seriously is pretty [ __ ]
ridiculous so this podcast is brought to
you by the vino vivino my friends is the
largest online wine community with 50
million users who have rated and
reviewed just about every wine i love
this app because it makes the wine
shopping experience so damn easy you
have no idea on the app you can see all
the ratings and reviews of wines you
might be interested in to get you a
better feel for what you're buying i am
not a wine buff at all but i do like
drinking it and they describe what i
might like really well and it helps me
buy a bottle of wine with confidence
without all the frou-frou stuff actually
i just recently started hearing about
natural wines so i looked up a couple of
reviews on vivino that were in the right
price range had great descriptors and i
bought a couple of bottles and i cannot
wait to receive it and i don't know i'm
gonna like it because i bought plenty of
stuff from aveeno before and it was
right on the money i've really stepped
up my wine game thanks to the vino give
them a try and i know you're going to
love it go to vivino.com brain and use
code brain and check out to save twenty
percent on your first order of up to two
hundred dollars that's v i v i n o dot
com slash brain code brain to save
twenty percent on your first order of up
to two hundred dollars that's the
vino.com slash brain code brain see site
for details terms apply
when you have a business they have loss
prevention right yeah but most
businesses a lot for about 10 of your
merchandise to be stolen that's just
really what it is you steal batteries
most people like how that other person
who stole that small amount of batteries
they just let it go because what is the
point you lose five bucks three bucks in
profit yeah does it does it really
require this whole [ __ ] scene right
absolutely not especially for some some
young person like what the [ __ ] what was
to happen like you do this whole fiasco
and then you were never going to steal
batters again i bet you this full sold
38 batteries after that did you no i
actually never stole again after that it
did work never mind i was like
i was like no because i was like dude
[ __ ] all that [ __ ]
jail sucks bro even today i was like
this is the like just it's so boring
you're just there in a room like i just
pictured you with the 10 cups
man yeah please i got this new reggie in
my [ __ ] cell guys
how'd he get in my cell though yo i
already had a tear dropping [ __ ] already
a tattoo you got tattoo on your back
it's just a patch of a battery that's
unplugged from before double a baby
they call me triple a that's pretty bad
you didn't know what he was in there for
i forgot i think he was in there for
stealing or something too there a bunch
of them were duis like a lot i remember
because in the morning there was a bunch
of guys and they were most of them were
there for duis i had a buddy who uh he
told me the story when he was younger he
was like super bad but
he
got into this like fight he used to like
drag race or some [ __ ] and this is when
he was out in new york but him and this
other dude got into it or some other
[ __ ] and uh they both had to go to jail
new york's jail system is pretty [ __ ]
up so
if you don't get to talk to a lawyer or
make your phone call for
to make some [ __ ] happen i guess after a
certain a lot amount of time whether
it's a week or two weeks if nobody
if you can't see a judge that's what it
is within two weeks you just get sent
straight to rikers for real yeah if you
don't see a judge within two weeks what
kind of [ __ ] is that well i don't
[ __ ] know but he was telling me the
story where he was
in jail and there was his dude
the dude that he went to jail that he
[ __ ] hates was sitting right across
from him and they're literally mugging
each other
and
all it took was somebody to say some
[ __ ] or just like make a noise and he
goes like you want to get [ __ ] up and
they started scrapping in the jail and
so the cops separated them and they left
them apart and a few days passes or
whatever
and he's like a couple days away from
being sent to rikers
and so he starts screaming at the
[ __ ] the jail people right he's just
like yo what the [ __ ] let me see my
[ __ ] lord let me see a [ __ ] judge
so i can get the [ __ ] out of here starts
cursing him he says the guys look at him
they go all right and they move around
and he's like a day away
he had one more day to see a judge or he
had to go straight to rikers holy [ __ ]
he has to wait to see a judge at rikers
island
and so he just goes oh he starts
[ __ ] his ass is hanging yeah and then
he talks to the guy he goes excuse me
sir uh i'd like to apologize for my
behavior he goes i'm a little stressed
out because i haven't been able to see a
judge i apologize for the way i was
speaking before he looks at me goes one
second
goes away comes back he goes you're
going to see a judge tomorrow wow
the way that you spoke to me he goes i
have i control your life
i can ignore you this whole time and the
only reason why you're seeing a judge
tomorrow is because you apologize to me
wow
[Music]
getting their lives ruined because
they're not being polite and [ __ ] isn't
that polite [ __ ] crazy crazy
sometimes [ __ ] have too much
power well the whole prison guard thing
is so creepy like that amount like
they're dicks bro like they're super
dicks to you because it's like what the
[ __ ] are you gonna do
they have ultimate power over you that's
insane jail [ __ ] scares the [ __ ] out of
it oh yeah yeah there was uh what's it
called like uh i had a podcast with a
couple of buddies of mine and they were
talking about this show i watched a
couple episodes but it's like jail all
across the world
and there was an episode where
it's a guy who's doing this documentary
documentary series and he basically sees
the worst jails in the world in panama
[ __ ] russia like all over the place
our jail system is the sweetest jail
system you've ever seen in your life
there's like places like in south
america where they drop you off the jail
system is literally a village
where the the gangs and the drug lords
run everything but it's a jail you see
the salvadorian ones where like all the
guys the ms-13 dudes are just stacked on
top of each other and these small little
like chicken coops and [ __ ] that's
really what it is that's so crazy so i'm
trying to go to the jail where they do
dances and they do a choreography
everything those yeah i have seen them
i'm trying to go to that jail that's the
job i'm trying of course you would
little [ __ ] loser
[Music]
you fit right in yeah i'm in bro you
know how you know joe's back you know i
know you know jail's bad is remember
they did that that there's like a famous
experiment they did it with students
yeah it was like harvard yeah and and
this prison guard students started
beating the [ __ ] and like just
do you know about this no so there was
like some it's like a famous study where
they they were like okay let's do a mock
jail scenario so
half of the students are going to be
prison guards half are going to be
prisoners
and like within like
super fast relatively quickly
yeah i don't know about minutes but like
pretty quickly seconds somehow the
prison guards started massive the
students that were prison guards started
massively abusing their powers and like
like starving dudes and like beating
them and like where was the point where
it's like yo don't you this is an
experiment [ __ ] like
third period like that's me and you dog
you're not a prison guard [ __ ] relax
but like somehow psychologically just
the fact that these dudes had the power
corrupted them so much that they like
all forgot about the ex like it was the
craziest [ __ ] so if that could happen to
[ __ ] in high school yeah like
what imagine crazy now legitimately you
like look at their classmates that they
know yeah and they were like they would
treat them like [ __ ] like this is not
having lunch no
why are you talking like that
you never spoke like that before yeah i
guess you went to clean for a
[ __ ] reason
[Laughter]
you're from beverly hills
that's so crazy she's rubbing these
[ __ ] screech that's why we need
some sweet tea baby
better make that sweet tea in that
toilet little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he's a pringle can't make a [ __ ] out of
it
he's like learning all this lego on
google so this is how they talk hold my
pocket
get over hold my pocket my pocket that's
right you ever heard of a [ __ ] bunny
[ __ ] what's that i take my pockets
out and look like a bunny you know you
have to suck my dick boy
grab my ears and suck my dick [ __ ] a
bunny [ __ ] funny blow job hold my
pockets
[Laughter]
yeah so if that shit's happening like i
got imagine yeah like you said it's real
like power that [ __ ] people up people
get [ __ ] power hungry that's why like
uh canceling people super hot that's for
sure why they love the [ __ ] power the
rush bro it's not even about the
whatever the cops i didn't give a [ __ ] i
did this [ __ ] video the other day
about this oh i wanted to ask you about
that so okay so this is what happened i
did this video right and by the way i
put up this video and it's just me
making jokes about how bad bad of a
dancer she is she wasn't very terrible
but it's like this is cute that's the
joke yeah it's this cute asian girl and
she's a little bit off rhythm right and
she's like literally whipping that [ __ ]
like she [ __ ] hates herself and i'm
cracking the [ __ ] up i was like oh this
would be a [ __ ] light joke thing it
was a very light roast which a majority
of people did but then a couple people
came on they're like oh you're [ __ ]
bullying her it's like bro people love
using that word they're like love that
word bullying that girl dm me she goes
why did you take the video down she was
it was so funny i was like i didn't take
the video down they deleted it she goes
i was okay with it like it was it was
like it was a super light roasting yeah
i was like yeah i thought it was pretty
light too it was very [ __ ] light the
girl messaged me and said it was [ __ ]
funny the girl that was getting clowns
[ __ ] bro yeah and people are like and
it's funny because i got all these
random comments [ __ ] dude and they
reported the video specifically they
reported that's why i got something they
reported the video but everybody was one
of them they wanted to be the hero they
wanted to be the social justice hero
that's standing up to a bully and they
wanted the pat on the [ __ ] back they
wanted from this chick and this girl and
the girl who [ __ ] by the way she's
dope as [ __ ] she's like i don't get it
she goes why are people so [ __ ] mad
it's not that bad that's what
i was gonna say like people are [ __ ]
but that's not really what it it what it
is is what you just said it's like they
just want the there's a power associated
to it it's all about like
it's just a social clout [ __ ] the way
you get social marriage dude i had a
homie that [ __ ] wrote a comment too
which i'm gonna roast him now in this
comment he goes bro i know the
choreographer who did this dance she
didn't choreograph it herself it was a
trend i was like
no [ __ ] it's a trend that's not what i'm
making fun of i'm just saying it's a
goofy [ __ ] dance yeah and he writes
this whole thing he goes oh it's the
thing he was like and it wasn't that bad
there's so many dances that are worse i
was like do you are you trying to get a
pat on the back from the youth is it
because your channel has died now you're
trying to like [ __ ] make sure that
the young people know you're cool yeah
like
you know me for years i'm the wrong one
to do that too bro you look [ __ ] dumb
because guess what the video went back
up i didn't see another comment
where'd your comment go
you know why because you found out that
most people found it funny and you
wanted the young people to like you and
give you a pat on the back
don't [ __ ] with me man i love you but
it's also it's it's your type of content
exactly that's what you do it's also
like
i'm making fun of somebody like that's
the whole this is what's happening like
it's you call her a [ __ ] nope do you
call her she's ugly she's a [ __ ] no
something like that no that's a problem
bro it was me making fun of a video of
her dancing because she could not even
if you did
like whatever and she's
and by the way
you guys call her a dumb stupid ugly
[ __ ] it doesn't matter bro and check it
out this girl cute as [ __ ]
she's cute as [ __ ]
and she has a following life's good she
actually gained like another like
thousand followers from yeah we're out
here let's go and people love her for it
it's like bro joking and making fun of
people is not a [ __ ] crime yeah
against humanity like it's gonna be that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] god trying to make it
be like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
the clapback you know it's
i was surprised that somebody that's a
youtube constituent was like dude i got
to be a social justice warrior i can't
believe you're making fun of this girl
it's like bro nobody respects you for
that suck you my dick yeah you get you
get you
you and i are friends i love you to
death but bro that was [ __ ]
embarrassing because you didn't follow
up with a second comment did you because
when the second video back i'm gonna
speak for him he didn't write a comment
again because he's like oh my god uh
people found it funny no [ __ ] guy what
the [ __ ] you've been watching my content
for 10 [ __ ] years and now you're
shocked when you [ __ ] out here when you
first posted it did you get a lot more
like of course there was a lot more
likes but then it got taken down no the
first one did you get a lot more
negative comments oh there was like
seven or eight negative comments it
wasn't that big so i left it up
it got taken down people reported it
and that girl's boyfriend was laughing
it was like you're funny yeah you know
you're not being malicious absolutely
so dude if you're doing a dance that's
popular on a tick tock you're gonna get
made fun of and that's fine hey it's
okay to get made fun like [ __ ] off like
it's okay bro kev on stage just the
sweetest dude ever makes fun of people's
dances on all the time but i do it and
it's like oh you're a bully i was like
hold on a second dude here's the thing
too when you put content out on the
internet for you to get eyes on you so
you could become famous you're subjected
to this exactly you get the good and
also the bad the fact that you're trying
to stop that is [ __ ] dumb
it doesn't make sense well and also just
be like i don't know where how this
happened but making fun of someone and
bullying have somehow become something
the same thing and it's not i mean you
could be you can be mean and make fun of
somebody but you can also be me make fun
of somebody and be just like it's like
jovial just cool it's just i didn't call
her
right i didn't tell her to stop dancing
any of that [ __ ] it's like
and also like even stop dancing yeah
even the guys that when but but even
like the arena like the patrice o'neal
where some of his humor was mean but it
was still [ __ ] funny and it was just
there's still value there too
but it's not all necessarily evil just
to make fun of them well everybody wants
the pats on their [ __ ] back right
what kind of world are we gonna live in
where you just can't [ __ ] just joke
around with a [ __ ] yeah and and
like laugh at yourself like how are you
scroll out what the [ __ ] is her name i
want to see i want to see this video her
name
[Laughter]
hilarious
bad dude
her name is savant young no
damn you got a fat old ass
follow him bro
she got a little dump truck on him too
oh she changed her name but oh no no she
didn't her name is cassie her name is
bad gal cass cass she's like a fitness
influencer cute got a nice little b-cup
booty b-cups nice little
booty she's from sydney australia she's
a guy
i shouted her out she's dope as [ __ ]
dude and she was like it was funny it
was light-hearted exactly i was like how
the [ __ ] are you mad at this [ __ ]
they're like one dude this guy was
hilarious he looks like a version of me
can i say something about the guys
though the guys that are standing up for
this girl ridiculous they're trying to
[ __ ] bro yeah like you're not she's not
gonna [ __ ] you yeah dude like guys like
that that try to stand for women like
that when especially when it's
completely they miss the boat on it yeah
like they completely missed the point
it's just not your place to like make
fun of a woman in her own space
feeling her own body and she gets this
guy nobody's gonna [ __ ] that guy bro
never will you get [ __ ] you can never
[ __ ] another girl like that if you're
cheating on other guys like that like
that's not how that's what your passion
is there's this [ __ ] guy
[ __ ] got a weak dick bro
he goes oh you feel so much better
making fun of somebody else's for
content and i was like wild and out taj
point oh this has been around for
[ __ ] years what are you talking about
while now it's the most popular tv on
vh1 i bet his [ __ ] picture was the
egg and [ __ ] right now this picture was
he looks like me if i was flamboyant gay
that's what he looks like and he's like
one of those he's really not [ __ ]
nobody his title was like self-professed
supermodel posing in all this other [ __ ]
in the most goddess [ __ ] clothes it's
like bro
we get it relax
like you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ] extra
i [ __ ] get it and so he wrote this
whole comment and i'm like i wrote a
list of all these [ __ ] shows based on
everything that people like and he had a
[ __ ] video with wildton out on it i
was like this show is made is literally
people making fun of each other they say
crazy [ __ ] on that too except crazier
way crazier [ __ ] [ __ ] racist [ __ ] all
the time it's just like bro get off your
[ __ ] high horse and i made this
example on my story where people
literally use memes yeah i saw that i
saw that that was good i was like very
good these are actual human beings by
the way but you use them as examples and
the reason why like i said too the
reason why you're okay making fun of
those people and those memes is because
number one it's not you and number two
they're fat
they're traditionally not attractive
they're ugly as you guys would like easy
to make fun of exactly so it's it's okay
for you to make people make fun of
people who are easy to make fun of
they're not attractive but this girl's a
cute girl so you're like oh you can't
[ __ ] attack her but you're okay with
attacking somebody who you think is
[ __ ] hideous and a [ __ ] social
pariah like you're terrible that's so
dumb yeah it's so crazy bro you're
[ __ ] terrible everyone
everyone can be made fun of at all times
yeah exactly at all times
anybody can get it
and i mean that's including me including
all of it it's just that's just part of
the game and honestly you want to hang
out with people that you could [ __ ]
make fun of yeah we want to talk [ __ ]
sometimes like it's fine it's okay
we don't hate each other afterwards i do
i know all you guys after the podcast
but it's fun you know what it's like
it's like when you see like dogs dogs
and cats and they like when they play
they like [ __ ] each other they're
they're actually practicing how to kill
somebody yeah that's really what they're
doing they're like biting each other
this is like a dog's true another dog's
face like this that's eating his face
and it's cute but really they're
practicing how to kill somebody that's
like what it's like when we're just
talking [ __ ] yeah i mean we're not
practicing to kill people but you know
you're just it's just fun sharpening
your mind it's like it's like verbal
sparring it's just fun and you want to
hear the craziest [ __ ] is this girl
gained a following and people liked her
more because she thought it was funny
yeah
yeah because for she's likable it's
likeable if you can get made fun of and
it's all good yeah people like people
that know how to take a [ __ ] joke if
you're the [ __ ] debbie downer in the
group where everything is so serious
where you have to make things a
political and [ __ ] social statement
who the [ __ ] wants to be around you you
[ __ ] trash bags yeah like
literally what do you think is gonna
[ __ ] happen you go hold on a second
guys can i tell you about the history of
bullying this is what you can do you can
literally take the single hair off my
left nut sack and thread it in your
mouth and use it as floss shut the [ __ ]
up [ __ ] yeah and his hair is strong
it'll last yeah it's curly too it'll
take all your plaque out nice the
tensile strength is unreal but you know
when people are bitching about the stuff
you know it's not because their heart is
in the right place it's not it's not
it's virtue signaling it's it's going
back to what you talk about this this
new social currency this new social
merit that maybe you'll think that oh
man this person thinks i'm a good person
that's what it's about right but it's
also if
who gives a [ __ ] it doesn't matter like
you're not going to achieve anything by
telling this guy that he's making fun of
uh this person and it's wrong because at
the end of the day it doesn't [ __ ]
matter none of this [ __ ] [ __ ] matters
people need to stop being soft i love
you yeah i mean i love you you [ __ ]
shout out cassie bro cassie you know a
round of applause for [ __ ] cats
for you know just being real cool yeah
man super cool and aj rafael stop being
a [ __ ] dude i [ __ ] love you bro
you're the homie but [ __ ] you
nice try dude nice try trying to be a
woke warrior bro yeah [ __ ] man
it's funny
it's fun it's crazy and you'll never run
out of things to talk about if you're
trying to be this guy if you're trying
to be this woke person
there's bigger things to worry about bro
do you think people in papua new guinea
are worrying about [ __ ] you know
social constructs so funny i think the
weird thing about his comment was that
he was name-dropping that he knows the
guy who choreographed the thing it's
like bro this is so crazy
this is so [ __ ] cringy what are you
doing our life is too good bro we have
we have we don't have things to worry
about anymore that's hard to worry about
this type of [ __ ] bro like like latinx
for example like in mexico no like
nobody gives it if i told my mom to call
me latinx what she called me a [ __ ] so
fast
she'd be like
yeah
she'd be like
yeah bro it's like it's just we're too
safe is this it's specifically this
country right because i i ask a lot of
fans who are like in europe and then um
um not asia but like some other
countries like greece
but they're kind of like americans are
obsessed with race like they can't yeah
they're always obsessed with all these
small bookkeepings like who cares people
are people they always say that [ __ ]
like if you're listening to this podcast
and you're not from the states i'm
pretty sure you can agree i always get
this like dms about this they're like
what the [ __ ] why are americans so
uptight like [ __ ] relax right well
it's our big it's like our biggest sin
right i mean the race has been our
biggest sense that's true and that's the
thing is like we don't we're not
handling it in a healthy way like yeah
and in in some senses humor is actually
probably the best way to deal with it
yeah you know that's why comedy that's
why that's that's the best way to deal
with the differences that we have we
just joke around we laugh and we like
learn about each other in a funny cool
way you know because it's just most of
it's just ignorance
but um i mean america is a social
experiment we i think we forget that
sometimes it is wild that we have all
these cultures and actually we've done i
mean obviously shit's been [ __ ] up too
but like the fact that it's worked at
all is pretty wild i mean like that you
can have a dude that's from [ __ ]
india living next to a dude that's from
england it's like or or that's probably
a bad example but or greece or whatever
it's just something where it's just
completely different you're like what
the [ __ ] and somehow you figure it out
you know
and the old the only thing that comes
out of it is that you make fun of this
guy's food from time to time like that's
not that bad yeah
and then you're still cool like that's
actually kind of dope yeah in front of
my food bro why
why is it
that anything that's negative right
breaks you down now like it breaks you
down to the softest baby i can't work
because of this i lost sleep because of
this you do not deserve to be in this
world everybody has anxiety now right
yeah it's like it's like the new [ __ ]
trigger thing i'm telling you man i and
by the way like i have crazy anxiety
right i still i'm still good
you still manage it i'm still learning
to manage it i'm still learning to like
adjust to things but i think the weird
thing is that we're trying to make in
the united states not in other countries
but this country specifically we're
trying to make sure that nobody ever
feels pain yeah
impossible
impossible you are going to be dis
uncomfortable people are going to make
fun of you people are going to [ __ ]
clown on you 24 [ __ ] seven that's how
it's going to be for the rest of your
life get [ __ ] used to it you can keep
doing these marches about like no more
bullying which i do agree i hate bullies
right it's gonna happen though we gotta
learn how to manage bullies rather than
just trying to stop this phenomenon
that's been happening not even phenomena
it's just a way of life for [ __ ] this
is the beginning of man it's not going
anywhere it's not it's always gonna be
around like i had a client who like
worked in the past and she was telling
me that she goes oh we don't like to
talk about food around our daughter yada
yada yada and it's like well she has a
weird relationship with food and i'm
like okay but what the [ __ ] is she gonna
do
she's gonna eat
she's gonna die we're just not gonna
talk about
like what happens if someone brings up a
sandwich around or she's like oh my god
like i have anxiety i understand it's
not it's not a joke or anything like
that but at the same time it's like how
do you solve this stuff you have to
address it if you don't address it it's
always going to be this open sore and
you're going to [ __ ] crumble any time
this comes around and it's going to come
around so why not address it now right
it's like what do we do not even that
like as a [ __ ] parent do you think
that you're going to be there to protect
your child 24 [ __ ] seven the world
doesn't stop for your child's specific
doesn't stop for nobody because none of
us are [ __ ] and it doesn't matter like
we ain't [ __ ] across the board no one's
more important than anybody else we had
to check one of our friends at a [ __ ]
party right because
this person kept bringing their young
child to adult parties where we're
drinking we're smoking having fun
and this girl comes up to me and she
goes hey stop cursing in front of my kid
[ __ ] out of here dude wow i was like out
of here
i was like this is a party you brought
your kid into an adult situation that's
your responsibility as a parent it's not
my fault you didn't find a [ __ ]
babysitter yeah this is a party what the
[ __ ] are you talking about worst parent
on earth and it's just cocaine [ __ ]
i was like i'm gonna do this later lily
literally as she was yelling at me i was
like hold on are you
[ __ ] insane
are you serious hey if timmy keeps
hanging around he's going to be the
coolest kid
he's going to get adult [ __ ] you know
mommy this party's lit
it's like the audacity yeah
of this girl to come up to me to tell me
to stop doing what adults do in an adult
situation when you brought your kid to
an adult area yeah that's crazy and by
the way it's not like this party had a
bunch of kids he was the only kid yeah
that's crazy
how how is this good this kid at the
time was like
12. that's crazy bro what i would never
bring
i i mean mine is four right now but like
a 12 year old to a [ __ ] partner like
unless she's cool though if she can
handle she can she's the dumbest thing
it's like take that beer back
on the head
take it to the doctor
[ __ ]
yeah but it's weird man that's an
example of parenting where they want the
world to cater to their child that's
crazy that's not the way it goes
that's why but how i don't understand
how she whoever that was thought
then our friend had to come in and be
like nah he's right like we're here at a
party you brought your kid here we're
hammered what are you talking
my about right here you're talking about
[ __ ] like all these sex jokes we're
at a [ __ ] adult party what are you
talking about [ __ ] and timmy knows what
the time it is bro he's 12. yeah the
internet yeah this one's like a [ __ ]
yeah he's like 69 dp's yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yo uncle david told me about bunny
[ __ ]
he's walking around he's like yo hold my
pocket uncle david i had to pass the
pitch to hold my pockets you get today
timmy's dope bro
i want to party with tv where's tv
[ __ ] made me some sweet teeth
yo [ __ ] this is hella random but
like i said one of the most saddest
[ __ ] videos where there was did you
see the [ __ ] online where this uh it was
a rapper
that was [ __ ] facetiming one of his
homies
on uh on instagram live i think i know
how this goes this dude got capped on
instagram
oh what straight up like you see him
going you hear papa pop
glass shattering everywhere i forgot how
many [ __ ] it's christ and you could
tell he got shot through his lungs and
his homies like yo where are you and
he's like
because he he got shot through his lungs
oh so he couldn't breathe
who's the rapper oh [ __ ] i gotta look so
you see him like he's on camera being
like help me yeah he's like help me and
he's saying crenshaw because that's the
street that he's on oh my god literally
on instagram live you see this dude
getting murdered in broad daylight in
his car as he's instagramming live his
homie holy [ __ ] bro that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] shocking dude this happened
recently huh yeah let me i'ma rate this
so los angeles rapper shot to death
while filming self on instagram live
indian red boy dead at 21 21 years old
dude wow
shit's [ __ ] if you see that video
dude you'll be i've never seen somebody
get shot to death like that in that in
that intimate of a sense where he's like
literally gasping for i don't know if i
want to watch that damn yeah that's
rough that [ __ ] [ __ ] up my day dude
yeah and then i went into a spiral of
watching other people get murdered bro
next seven hours i wat my buddy sent me
this one video
the fact that it's on instagram but my
buddy sent me this one video of i think
it was i forgot it was somewhere in the
midwest it was snowing
guy comes outside he has an argument
with his neighbor guy comes out and
there's a husband and wife arguing with
their neighbor across the street the
neighbor leaves comes back out with a
gun shoots the wife
goes in the guy's running
back in the house he shoots him
goes back up to the wife shoots him in
the f shoots her in the [ __ ] head you
talk about the snow one right here in
the snow that [ __ ] [ __ ] my life up
like i was like i was thinking about
that [ __ ] for a whole [ __ ] week dude
can i just say something that may be
misinterpreted
a little bit but i want to say this
right now at first i saw that
traumatized yeah second time you left
traumatized third time
giggled just a little bit
the reason why is because if you watch
that video when you watch it you're
gonna be like whoa yeah the second time
you're gonna watch it be like whoa third
time you're gonna dissect it a little
bit funny as [ __ ] you get numb to it
a little bit this girl the wife right
gets shot up a million i'm talking about
shot in the dome right like a lot but
just to put it out there when women want
to talk [ __ ] they don't talk that [ __ ]
she got shot in the head and she was
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] she's still
talking [ __ ] and she has like 18 bullets
inside her hey you lit dick mother
my brain's still here like still i was
like this girl is the biggest gangster
i've ever seen conor mcgregor did super
hard that's the definition of keep that
same energy wow keep that same energy
crazy and i watched a 21 year old los
angeles rapper whose gang affiliate gets
shot up and he's like help me
this woman got shot [ __ ] to the guy
to the [ __ ] dude yeah oh my god yeah
[ __ ] that's wow that's some brave
hardship yeah
william that's some william wallace [ __ ]
right there
women have a higher threshold for pain
they don't care clearly for sure
[ __ ]
that's why you got weak dick
i mean that that fight of that video was
so insane because it was it was like an
ongoing
like battle that they had for maybe a
couple of weeks of that neighbor taking
their snow and throwing it on their
throwing on that dude's driveway what a
piece of [ __ ] well that guy is like an
ex expat or something he was in the
military and he kept on calling the
other guy kept on calling a piece of
[ __ ] he's like you're such a piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] it wasn't that big of an
insult but because their altercation was
going on for so long he got [ __ ] mad
up he came out with a gun and the woman
is the one that engaged and it was like
what are you going to do with that you
ain't going to do [ __ ]
that was crazy big mistake [ __ ]
capture right wow caps both of them he's
screaming ah help goes back in gets a
bigger gun she's still talking [ __ ] caps
both of them is still alive how do you
survive bro i don't how did you take so
many shots i don't know didn't they die
they died but they took a lot of bullets
and that girl let me tell you something
what the [ __ ] the video was it felt like
the longest video i've ever watched like
it just seems like it just took so long
for
him to go back in the house and just
shoot her like it just seemed it was
crazy bro it was i've never seen a video
like that ever one of the neighbors she
traumatized me because oh my god one of
the neighbors came out he was a teen and
he went up to the lady and was like are
you okay i was like yo what the [ __ ] do
you think god yeah she looks like swiss
cheese dude yeah
he's like are you okay i would have been
like in my last breath damn david really
dissected this video
he's telling me [ __ ] that i don't even
like remember watching that video
there's a kid that comes out he goes are
you okay and i'm like i would have my
last breath i would have been like you
are the dumbest person i've ever met
like why would you ask me that [ __ ] i
got i got [ __ ] executed like are you
and it was caught on like a ring or a
ring camera yo ring cameras are crazy
all the time
ring cameras are insane it's a recent
video
yeah this is pretty recent like a couple
months ago hey just go on neighborhood
app you will see people's true nature
come out on a neighborhood app people
will be talking [ __ ] dog hella [ __ ]
everybody
there's like lightweight low-key racist
[ __ ] that you could tell they're racist
but they want to make sure that other
people know
they want to see if other people are a
little racist yeah when they're fishing
they're fishing like they're thrown jabs
hey so i saw uh a dark figure that came
into my house around my house yesterday
seemed like a young male perhaps in the
african descent maybe
when i see people of this nature
they tend to like break in and steal a
lot
yeah their credit score is not that
great
yes
like god damn wow the neighborhood app
is the wildest [ __ ] dude all they do is
talk [ __ ] about people 24 [ __ ] seven
people are nuts bro
for some reason they think that
everybody's robbing them they're like i
s did you guys hear that weird noise
outside it was that yeah it was your
garbage can that fell over from a
raccoon you [ __ ] stuff like that bro
it's all the new apps everyone's
connected so they feel like they see all
that [ __ ] in the neighborhood to
absolutely think like that shit's
happening all the time i gotta download
that [ __ ] because i have the citizen app
but that one i people leave it just
shows you crimes that are like man stabs
dude in the chest like oh great the
[ __ ] stop sign it's like the
wilderness
[ __ ] like where is that happening bro
like man assaulting woman on this
whatever blah blah
and uh there's little comments but i i
only left one but it was just like like
it was like some some dude started a
fire or something and i just wrote like
everyone's like oh my god why would
people do this like there's kids around
here blah blah as ro that guy probably
likes to eat a lot of ass
and then that i don't think my comma got
approved
they deleted you about that like i want
to just join the neighborhood app so i
could just say something crazy [ __ ]
that would be fun there's always crazy
people around we just don't see it man
yeah like
how many of the sorry how many of the
neighborhood apps are on here are about
[ __ ] peacocks
bro what's up with the pico run those
over bro people people feed the peacocks
though well right now they're all the
eggs hatch so you see a little bunch of
baby pigs
[ __ ] bro are they cute but the normal
ones annoying dog they're weird they're
[ __ ] so loud they're arrogant they're
arrogant they're arrogant as [ __ ] they
peck people's cards when they see the
reflection apparently they just walk
around with like they're not afraid like
like i'll eat you dude yeah you're okay
with my car
you're kind of a turkey i wonder if i
want to fish
that's what i wonder i wonder if it's
like a little too ethnic that i want to
see what they taste like yeah i do want
to see what they taste has anyone like
can you eat peacock places you could eat
anything in this world yeah we got to
find her
children
pat if it got a heartbeat
that means that [ __ ] [ __ ] could be a
delicate chest yeah i guess
my question is where where are they
serving peacocks two weeks my backyard
that's where it's happening bro i'm a
laura peacock i'm gonna show it's my
dick and then i'm like oh [ __ ] answer it
that's awesome
yeah
he's like what's up what's that snake
oh [ __ ] never [ __ ] hit it on top of
his forehead knock it out
they get in the way these [ __ ]
walk around the street like there's no
cars
like figure it out i read an article
where they're gonna try to make sure
they're gonna get rid of the peacocks or
something yeah get rid of them bro we
don't need peacocks we don't need more
[ __ ] in the street to cause more
accidents i used to like peacocks and
then when you see them all the time not
that great man yeah they're annoying
they're just like i said arrogant
there's like a like they walk they just
stroll like like they look at you like
you know you know what people think
about like ducks and they're like oh
ducks are so cute you know ducks be out
here raping all the time dog ducks i
heard ducks raped raping they raped us
like seven males on one female and you
watch videos of them like dude cause i
think all animals kind of really they'd
be raping but this one looks especially
[ __ ] up and i saw that video i was
like yo man [ __ ] ducks that's why
chinese people eat ducks yo they taste
delicious there's there's seven ducks
like raped bro like gang rape dog rape
how do they gang rape it's like well
they've got you know what they're
getting right
now is that pigs or is that there's like
six of them holding her down and bro
they're just pecking at him and there's
pecking one and they're all trying to
[ __ ] like it's crazy watch follow this
page called nature is metal on instagram
all right
he used to follow it and then it started
grossing me out it gets crazy i love it
i love that [ __ ]
you sick [ __ ] man [ __ ] you but one of
the ones i didn't like was the ones of
of ducks getting raped yo i saw that
immediately i said [ __ ] ducks forever
[ __ ] ducks i don't need to see ducks you
know what you do you know what the
funniest thing about asia
there's always like these stereotypes
like yo [ __ ] you know don't put an
animal friend in the asian person like
they're gonna eat them but this is true
though hey brother this is a better
people understand the moment i saw a
peacock in this neighborhood the first
thing i thought was like
in what way can i prepare this this
lovely foul
wow maybe a little plum sauce yeah maybe
garlic how would you how would you prep
a peacock what would you do well first i
chop off its head to clean off the
[ __ ] neck yeah drink the blood like
i'm a [ __ ] warrior yeah
asgard what you're gonna do with the
feathers though the feathers i'm gonna
make a nice little [ __ ] silky-ass
conor mcgregor suit with it
i'm gonna do that and then i'm gonna
stuff the cavity with some chestnuts
all right some wild rice yeah okay right
cool and i'm going to put it into a nice
turkish oven yeah nice i'm going to
roast it
at this point yeah yep put it put a
little butter some seasoning on it right
butter slice it in half and throw it in
the garbage cans
[ __ ] are huge and weird looking
at [ __ ] that's exactly what i'm gonna
[ __ ] yeah i wonder why people don't
eat peacocks is it just because they're
pretty interesting i wonder if you can
can you are you gonna eat you could
literally eat anything that's not
poisonous people you see i mean i i mean
like is it cause you know you can't eat
certain things right it's not least not
legal right that should that should be
it's protected by the city of arcadia
which is like that's what i'm saying
whatever so if you get them outside of
arcadia it's like donations
i
it's just a bunch of art media people
don't come here bro this is not for you
but peacock stay home
i wonder what they taste like though
like probably like uh turkey uh
what do you call pigeon the fancy
version of it uh a quail quail probably
there's like no quail is a different
type of bird it's uh
what do you call [ __ ] pigeon man i
know this [ __ ] dude they serve that [ __ ]
it's fancy as [ __ ] when you serve it uh
he's like would you let me see
what's the french do a french accent for
me real quick uh hold on i'm looking it
up pitching oh no i can't um
have you uh squab squad squad squab
sounds like a shitty word
doesn't sound fantastic
but pigeons actually what i found out
were actually brought here for food
like for us to eat yeah squab and they
got and they apparently they multiply so
fast that they're just all over the
place but pigeons were brought here as
food like like cattle or oh really i
don't know how they're all over the
place there's some fat ass pigeons out
there sometimes you ever see some fat
[ __ ] pigeons dude [ __ ] thick it's
thick
thick ass like big-ass godfather [ __ ]
pigeons where i'm like like you catch
capture a pigeon you could [ __ ] eat
it oh look check it out
peacock is not illegal to eat
oh for real type in where can i eat some
people they say like these are a
restaurant the most common place you'll
find domestic peacock meat is in
california hey check it out though so we
could eat it
youtube video peafowl or peacock next
week
david still cooks a peacock
easy that's it alive delicious yeah hunt
it you gotta get the video of you
hunting it too they're saying that it
tastes like chicken but others claim
that it tastes similar to turkey when
brined
others compare the taste to guinea pig
that's random as [ __ ] what person in the
states knows what [ __ ] guinea pig
tastes like yeah i guess that people eat
that [ __ ] south america people eat it
like nothing because my buddy was out
there in the peace corps yeah
like crazy
they just had a kitty pig
and they they didn't like prep them they
weren't like hey you're about to eat a
guinea pig this is what we eat [ __ ]
like this is your [ __ ] dinner this is
what you're gonna [ __ ] yeah eat this
[ __ ] the the pet dude sam his name
was sam yeah bro damn
everything that we keep as pets other
people eat in other countries we have a
weird aversion towards like specific
foods but i'll tell you this man i think
because i'm going uh i'm learning a lot
of empathy now
i'll be looking at animals differently
like
you trying to eat all the animals
like wait wait wait because you're wait
that's something doesn't make sense
because you're like i'm getting empathy
now i'll be looking at all animals as
food
i'm gonna eat those [ __ ] no
like the animals that look as food now
they have lives yeah like my empathy
growing like my heart's scaling oh okay
like you don't want to eat them i saw it
i saw a video that you did it almost put
me off pork for a second oh wow because
they're highly intelligent animals they
have like human-like eyes [ __ ] creep
me out dude i was like damn i'm almost
gonna give up pork wow hey but if you
were locked in a room for the rest of
your life
with a pig
you know with just the pig and you
decided to not eat the pig that pig was
going to [ __ ] eat you oh sure yeah
you got to eat that [ __ ] pig i'm
saying
because i had carnitas that night
yeah
pork is [ __ ] amazing dude but the
fact that it's weird because i almost
didn't eat beef why didn't eat beef when
i was younger a lot either just because
sacramento has a huge agriculture
program like all these schools i saw a
baby cow a calf yeah [ __ ] cute
as [ __ ] dude these big old [ __ ] eyes
they wag their stupid ass [ __ ] tail
they're happy to see you
they know and i haven't eaten veal since
wow really i didn't know veal was baby
cow i haven't yeah that's kind of funny
that's kind of sad huh yeah but the
thing is like i'll eat whatever i just
i'm not i you just don't have to torture
the [ __ ] thing yeah no you don't
factory farming [ __ ] is [ __ ] up you
have to like put it in a little cage and
like cuss it out every once in a while
whatever the [ __ ] they do you're a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you know nothing
[Laughter]
give it therapy first before you kill it
what was the relationship like with you
and your father chicken
the rooster well bakar
kill that [ __ ] you feel good
good
i love it well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast
that's fast that flew by bro i flew by
real quick so i don't know let me tell
you something because we poured a hefty
amount of we did i told you it wasn't
enough for you
this [ __ ] drinks dude and i had
some too i had a couple of
[Laughter]
i was like i need a little drink
you can catch nick the ear at nick the
ear
what's up bang bang you could also see
it but i was podcast it's mma boys yeah
we out here
actually i like mma boys better yeah a
little bit that's pretty good yeah
whatever yeah we out here
mma yeah you can find patrick at
patrick.tdot riley standup is in cat
follow him on his instagram to see when
his shows are coming out so you guys can
catch all the [ __ ] funnies it'll be
hilarious
i love it
i drank too much yeah boys
that's all good we got another podcast
coming out next every thursday sundays
genius brain baby let's go i've had sex
with your
and that's all the mother baby let's go